chez jean claude lattès nicolas hulot
nous le connaissons tous mais de temps
en temps même très sauvage à la chaîne
concurrente ou swelia fameux magazine de
la nature et moi je dérapais en lisant
votre livre de voir qu'il y avait en
fait en vous une grande déchirure vous
avez une une enfance non je ne
soupçonnais pas qu'elle avait été
finalement dramatique assure toi un
frère qui se suicident des parents qui
divorcent votre père qui fut lui-même de
tentatives de suicide avant de mourir
d'un cancer lourd héritage familial
ça peu délicat d'en parler par aucun
thème du livre je crois que nous avons
des bus ce livre qui fait effectivement
référence à des périodes un peu un peu
lourde et qui vous accompagne toute une
vie j'ai voulu expliquer ou en tout cas
donner un sens un certain nombre de mes
acquis des comportements aujourd'hui je
vous l'expliquais que quelle que soit la
profondeur des cabines lequel on puisse
passer il faut s'accrocher parce qu'il
ya un moment où nous laisser un peu de
temps libre en est que ça veut quand
même le coup de deux bien géré assez ces
épreuves que la vie vous infliger un
gain de temps est ce la raison pour
laquelle vous risquez pratiquement
chaque fois votre vie dans un reportage
nom des marges je pense que
contrairement à peut-être alignera aussi
je suis loin de ce qu'il m'a mis dans
chacun des reportages en tout cas je ne
ne risque pas pour la télévision il est
arrivé à titre personnel mes expéditions
je vais nourrir eux-mêmes pour des
vraiment pour
accompagner un projet que j'avais dît si
dans ma tête mais pas la télévision dans
les choses sont différentes la
télévision c'est vrai qu'un système
d'émission qui peut qui est un peu
spectaculaire mais le risque n'est pas
un ingrédient indispensable au plaisir
je crois que le rx est un peu le tribut
à payer aux émotions qu'on convoite
c'est vrai quand on décide d'aller
survoler le pôle nord une meule m il
faut payer le prix du danger parce que
c'est plus dangereux c'est vrai d'aller
sur le la banquise au moyen d'un engin
rudimentaire articles l mais c'est pas
la raison je crois que c'est vrai gossip
aujourd'hui je consomme lobby d'une
certaine manière si je suis attirée vers
les camps disent pas si je suis séduit
par le charisme de certaines personnes
limité certains personnages si j'ai
décidé effectivement d'emprunter
certains chemins de traverse c'est
peut-être prendre un peu de distance
avec un passé qui était difficile de
digérer les gens vous n'avez pas
la fameuse famille lodden lacoste
c'est pas ça se prépare une question dit
me d'une pas aimer de jeu j'ai écrit ce
livre dans une totale sérénité sans
rancoeur sans haine je voulus par contre
sur un certain nombre de leçons et
d'enseignement j'ai dit dans ce livre
j'ai essayé en tout cas de dire à ce que
les lully
refusé l'uniformité refuser les sillons
que l'on trace pour vous refusez de vous
laisser enfermer dans un système que
vous n'avez pas choisi je voulais juste
faire passer un message c'est de dire la
vraie réussite ce n'est pas la manière
dont est habillée ou le titre que vous
avez sur une carte de visite ou la
portance de le contrôle de votre compte
en banque j'ai voulu dire la réussite
c'est de vivre le plus proche possible
de sa vraie nature encore faut-il
découvrir sa vraie nature et sagem pour
laquelle vous êtes critique avec
certains journaux certains radio
certains télévision diront certains
médias critiquent ce petit 9-6 c'est un
constat moi je sais que aujourd'hui j'ai
33 ans j'ai fait une petite apparition
dans ce milieu il ya une dizaine
d'années une douzaine d'années avec un
certain nombre d'idées gens que j'ai dû
déposer en route c'est vrai que c'est un
milieu que ce soit la division où la
presse en général on perd très
facilement ses illusions au début
notamment quand quand j'ai vu 18 20 ans
d'abord les ingouches un terrible et
puis on se fait une idée de ce qu'est le
journalisme et et très vite on vous dit
vis de cette idée c'est vrai que je
raconte dans ce livre que cocteau leur
entraîneur partage en afrique australe
où je voulais témoigner d'une certaine
détresse notamment au niveau des enfants
et quand je t'ai mal au portage parce
qu'une famille princière fait encore
parler d'elle c'est vrai qu'à un moment
ça vous agace ça vous irrite et puis
même un moment ça vous éclaire
définitivement mais croyez bien en tout
cas nicolas que xala 5 nous sommes très
vigilants el oued
des valeurs en tout cas ce que beaucoup
moins aux autres mais il ya des valeurs
nicolas boudot chemins de traverse chez
jean claude lattès merci nicolas dans un
instant la bourse avec frédéric désert